the most challenging part was to be
tough on tough
love I I used to think about Vince
Lombardi tough love tough
love you know you got to be that
toughness that then raises them to
another level and then when you give it
with love you got to give it with love
and I felt the love but also the need
for toughness and not
everybody you know some people rise and
they get the tough love and some people
uh you know it hurts and so if you were
communicating with people can you
communicate totally straightforward can
you say you don't have the maturity or
you don't
have the
toughness um how do you deal with that
interaction like I try to
be very straightforward I I would
say that's a weakness for you that's an
issue and that there's may be ability to
work around the issue in my case if you
find somebody who's weak at something
but they're good at something else you
compare them with somebody who's good at
what they're weak at in order to then so
you put together they work as a team
that way but still the recognition that
you're weak at that thing so when you're
dealing with people maybe it's because
they come to expect it that I'm coming
to a team and they're used to saying
okay you're weak at this you're strong
how's that go well actually that's it's
that's fairly easy because our opponent
are the guys on the other side of the
field so whatever our weaknesses is my
weakness another players's weakness
we're going to be attacked by our
opponents at that weakness so we we all
need to strengthen our weaknesses to
compete against our opponents as long as
it's direct uh it's really with the idea
of like let's get better and beat our
opponents and that that goes over pretty
well I think the thing that I always try
to avoid and is difficult is if it's
personal you know the personal criticism
is different than the professional
criticism um here's how you need to
prepare better here's how you need to
play better here's how you need to um
you know here's how I need to coach
better that's all to me that's all fine
uh it when it gets personal then that
then that gets into another you know
another level that then I think is more
destructive and constructive so we we
definitely avoid that at all costs uh
because nothing's personal it's all
committed towards winning
right